growing concerns that the irs is
building an army of new auditors and
some of them could be armed the new
democratic spending bill at nearly 87
000 new irs agents and now there's a
major uproar over a job posting from the
agency apparently looking for applicants
who can carry a firearm
and use deadly force if necessary judge
i sent some
a a sense that you want to talk on this
no i was laughing i mean what are they
going to do are they going to come in
and say
janine i want to see the last seven
years okay come on in here's my boxes
what are they going to do take out a gun
and take me in i mean
since wonders and iron i mean these
people first of all they're four eyes
all of them okay
i haven't heard that insult since second
grade
hey four eyes
okay i mean they're real geeks they're
real smart people they work with numbers
they're gonna carry a gun
is to make a dull job sound exciting and
cool
yeah you won't be sitting behind a desk
going through spreadsheets you're going
to be out in the field with a choice of
weaponry you're going to go you're going
to chase down vile criminals who didn't
declare their cash tips yeah and
housewives yes who may be in their house
dresses
i mean really thanks four eyes we
appreciate
well i think
i'm not going to denigrate the members
of the irs
irs commissioner is going to come out
tomorrow and have a press conference and
demand that we take back any insults to
the irs agents the number one negative
aspect of buildback better when they did
focus groups was the irs portion and now
i think democrats are having some regret
going all in on this irs deal because we
have proof
nonpartisan proof that you are five
times more likely to be audited the less
wealthy you are this goes on poor and
middle class taxpayers and senator mike
crapo of idaho put forward an amendment
when they were announcing this bill
saying
let can we put into this law that no one
making under four hundred thousand
dollars a year will get audited and
every democrat voted no
why would they want to vote no well
because in order to pay for the
inflation reduction act they had to find
the money somewhere where's the money
going to come from it's going to come
from you and it's going to come from
these audits and that's why they had to
do this they'll be coming back for more
pretty soon but basically they're trying
to audit the poor to buy the rich
electric vehicles
that's so sad
you won't be audited
trump audited me i couldn't believe it
after everything i've done for the man i
get this stupid audit letter
like right in the middle of the term i
was like what and uh so we had the
accountant go over stuff and i had to
just
you know go over everything yeah i owed
two not a lot but they got me and then i
fired my account and i have a great
account now i'll never ever owe anything
actually the irs is me but good luck you
don't need a gun as an irs agent you
just don't and what the government is
starting to do they're giving everybody
guns the epa has guns the interior the
irs now has guns they want to take your
guns away
right they want to take your guns away
but they want to give guns to the irs
you finished
now we've finished the one that one
percent excise tax also on that stock
buyback is how they're going to pay i
don't know what you're talking about
that's in the bill
up next
make my day texas governor greg abbott
dishing out another big threat to blue
cities upset over migrants hi everyone
i'm brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now